their faces are on the wall but they're
not
all in school at worthington primary two
classes
are at home isolating managing bubbles
isn't easy we've just returned one back
on monday of this week
another bubble tuesday of this week and
we have a bubble closed
as we speak and they're coming back on
monday of next week
staff when they are in close contact
with somebody who's got it that's
another problem
for pupils it's disruptive not just for
learning but their well-being too
it made me like sad when i went into
school like i heard all these stories
and just wanted to be there
it isn't nice because if you like need
to do the work then
you know you'd miss out on that and you
could struggle later on
over 600 000 children are out of school
due to covid but only four percent of
them have the virus
that's why bubbles are going keeping
children in consistent groups
was essential to control the spread of a
virus when our population
was less vaccinated we recognize that
the system of bubbles and isolation
is causing disruption to many children's
education
that is why we'll be ending bubbles and
transferring contract
contact tracing to the nhs test and
trace system
it's too late for 17 year old emily
she's stuck at home
isolating but welcomes the change i
would have been able to go back into
school
you know i've been lateral flow testing
every day and i've had two negative pcrs
and so being able to go in and have
those last days
i would have made the world of
difference it'll make a difference to
parents
too juggling jobs and home schooling
i think it's a good thing and especially
for the parents that are working
full-time
because then they've got switched their
whole life when they get a phone call
saying can you come and collect your kid
from school
as long as they protect their children
that's all that matters the current
controls have caused
chaos for children they've missed a
billion days in school
not everyone's happy with the changes
but most agree
the current disruption can't continue
laura bundock sky news